the protest against cobot 19 mandates
ended in february after 18 days when
police made arrests and seized a large
cache of weapons and ammunition anthony
olynyk jerry morin chris carbert and
chris lizack are charged with murder
conspiracy weapons offenses and mischief
according to the unsealed documents
undercover officers spoke to organizers
of the protest at smuggler's saloon
police allege olenick morin and carbert
were part of a subgroup with loose ties
to the leading organizers and that the
three participated in bringing firearms
into the coots blockade area the
documents also allege one of the
officers spoke to olenek who brought a
dump truck to the blockade and said he
was involved in security
and discussed having access to hundreds
of firearms and ammunition within coutes
key portions of the discussion with
olynyk involving a delivery believed to
be a bank of weapons remain under a
stealing order the documents also show
police were seeking a warrant to seize
papers relating to the financing of the
blockade an undercover officer allegedly
saw a man with an estimated 500 pages of
documents described as financial records
and police said conversations inside the
saloon alerted them to a finance
committee pointing to what they called a
governance structure police also wrote
that financial records will provide
evidence of people directly involved in
the blockade as well as those who
supplied money and resources making them
party to the name defense the
allegations in the newly released
documents have not been proven in court
the four accused are scheduled to stand
trial in june of 2023